what do you think do you think your mom
and dad are like somewhat related
my mom and dad aren't cousins or
anything i just wonder if back in the
day like if it's a long line of inbred
how far back do you think yeah if you
were inbred how far back back in the
christmas days got it guys
maybe that's like why we have bigger
noses i don't know
why do jewish people have bigger noses
you don't have a big nose but it's above
average
[Music]
what's up guys hi cats after dark
today we have a special guest
we have one guest that's missing and
today we have a special one ari
[ __ ] mantis thanks for having
me who's missing meatballs
and that's christian christian
oh i know christian yeah yeah
okay right now you know
are they a sponsor or do you want to
keep it private okay this is anonymous
alcoholic beverage yep yeah they don't
get they don't get that opportunity yeah
but if any seltzers would like to
sponsor
either the show or just me
as a seltzer influencer i'm i'm feeling
he's a heart he's a hard seltzer
influencer hard [ __ ] selfies are
scary the first time i had these i
literally didn't know there was alcohol
in them i thought it was a flavored
sparkling water so i had like three of
them
and all of a sudden i'm like what is
going on really oh
dude i had a non-alcoholic beer
uh why would you do that it was dude it
was it was crazy
i got i got like uh not triggered as
much as i was just like oh [ __ ] that's
what it tastes like i remember where
this tastes oh you're sober
not sober got it you just don't drink
hot potato i don't drink alcohol
i only smoke weed that's probably the
only thing
i'll do and all the coke you do
i remember the first time i ever did
coke or i did it twice yeah but it was
just so i felt like
the trashiest person
on earth
wait so what do you feel like on coke
because i feel like because i'm crazy
yeah
uh
are you crazy i feel like you're the
opposite of crazy well you still used to
be i was thinking i was thinking old
chapel well i was thinking
when did you do coke was it during your
alcoholic days uh yeah yeah 19 and 20.
but i was like this is trash and there's
like drip in the back of my throat it
was annoying i was like ew this is
[ __ ] i thought i just felt like
i don't know i've
not to just trailer parks but i feel
like
trailer trailer it's the opposite
trailer park people can't afford coke
they can't afford they're doing needle
[ __ ] yeah coke is for doctors and
lawyers so what's the cheap [ __ ]
yeah
it's cheaper that is right
that is right well i don't know i just
maybe it was bad coke and not you know
what trailer park people aren't trashy
people they're great people but you felt
trashy because though because you have
to like put on the table and use it you
know yeah that's that's what makes you
feel like [ __ ] yeah or you know like i
was in a dirty ass trailer because
there's some dirty ass trailers
absolutely right probably most of them
no don't don't say that about them and
then you end up you don't want to finish
it it depends what trailer park where's
this trailer park locate if it's in
malibu they're rich yeah okay if it's
trailer park like in
if it's right outside your hometown
they're probably not doing that good
should we go with west virginia
but cook
yo have you seen that uh that dude that
interviews uh
the family in west virginia uh and
they're they're all like inbreds oh
steve what's going on
i've seen that and there's a guy who
barks right like he can't communicate
normally but he doesn't yes because
because he's in
never
bread
yes
no that sounds awesome these these
screens aren't on uh nick
and the guy who's recording this
documentary eventually takes them to
walmart to go shop yeah he like helped
yeah he helps your family some people i
think he's like exploiting that avoiding
them or whatever and it's like no he
like he actually gets to he just a dude
that's just curious of their story he
takes him to walmart the most it's fancy
expensive store ever to give back yeah
bro
like but it's kind of cool he doesn't
just interview them he interviews like a
bunch of like different people just got
to go get a uh yeah sorry guys we gotta
go next week
actually
next week i won't be here because i go
to uh london london
london babies yeah you think if i went
there and said it that way they'd be
like oh you are from here yeah but
they'd also think you're a homosexual oh
so you'd it'd be a combo because the
kids it came off kind of you need an aim
for a very specific sound like what
accent do you want do you want to sound
posh you want to sound cockney
that's too complicated cockney's like
a tough yeah it's tough tough go
but anyways oh yeah that's what sorry i
was sidetracked uh
what was i talking about you're gonna be
in london so you're gonna miss next week
yeah i'll miss you what day do you leave
i'll leave tuesday
would you want to do monday we could
move it i don't know if you guys can do
monday i'll do mondays yeah let's see
how you do monday oh yeah then let's do
that cool yeah that's perfect
uh but anyways just family i've been so
intrigued by this family because they're
inbreds but i mean they all got like
weird eyes
you know because because because they're
off something's off yeah that's what
happens when first cousins or lower i i
think it was brother sister yeah that
would definitely happen for that i think
if it's a second cousin you're good yeah
i've looked a lot into this why is that
why yeah all right why do you yeah you
look into the weirdest [ __ ] are you
you're just that curious but i'm just
i'm curious uh
also i heard i don't know if this is
true or if this is just more
racism online but i heard that jews are
all in bread
really that's why i hurt why is it i was
a jewish guy i was like am i in bread
but like if you're inbred like
i don't think you come out normal
am i normal
you you look fine i'm talking about
physically i would assume because after
what i've seen of this but i i guess i
had to look into it further so don't let
me
don't let that be my final answer
don't take anything
look at me i don't know if it's true or
if it's bigger it's red and probably but
i heard i heard jews are in bread but
that could just be bigotry i don't know
because jews like to keep it in the
family i don't i've never dated a jewish
girl in my life
but jews
typically like uh there's a stereotype
oh you better bring home a nice jewish
girl to your your mom like that's the
only person that your parents are going
to approve of and i think that goes the
same in all religions if you're
religious you want your kids all right
we'll specify because there's different
types of jewish people
right religious jewish people which i am
not but i heard in religious jewish
people
marry a non-jew say it again they'll
disown you so if i my parents aren't
religious but if they were and i were to
marry
a cat they would disown me
is it the same with tattoos too like you
can't well you uh
they're they're against tattoos and you
can't be buried in a jewish cemetery
star of david cross lovers
wait so so if you wait the way they
would disown you you couldn't be buried
in a jewish cemetery because you married
no that's a tattoo thing you can't be
buried in jewish cemetery my if i were
to marry a non-jew they would just stop
talking to me i wouldn't be part of
their family anymore you'd be shocked
because that's real life not for my
family but a lot of people but like
traditional yes that's intense yeah
but i think it's the same if you're a
religious mormon or religious catholic
i'm pretty sure it's the same they would
if you were to bring home someone that's
not your religious your parents would
get really upset possibly disown you
so it was like if a white girl brought
me home exactly the same thing which is
what all the last n words involved
[Laughter]
i should get credit for that well you
could yeah
you get a gold star dude it's gotta be
that's gonna be a tough way to live man
it's almost kind of but i mean but if if
that's all you know
then that's all you know also if that's
what you want
that's what you want there's nothing
wrong with that but man like if you go
that i don't even think that's going
against it as much as you just found
another person that you're in love when
they just happen to be
of difference than your culture it's
that if in orthodox jewish people even
if you
just give up the religion
they disown you yeah it's like a cult
almost i think you give up your cult
you're out
there i'm not too familiar as far as
like the nation of islam but i think
i'm sure it's the same
it's got to be black
wait islam
you know why oh that is that the black
people like yeah like okay malcolm x
what malcolm x okay got it again i don't
know i'm not two in that world but i
believe it
yeah yeah i think so it might be this in
the same sense would you join that and
you had to go to services two times a
week let's say but in trade you would be
a theater act instantaneously no you
wouldn't do it no i do it right now i
joined
i joined islam right now to be a theater
oh hell yeah no i i don't know i i get
weird
with uh groups i like i don't i don't
necessarily like group
type of things or at least uh
to where you can't necessarily think for
yourself and you have to like follow
these specific guidelines that kind of
[ __ ] i just can't [ __ ] wrap my head
around so you won't join scientology
with tom cruise i'm sorry uh tom cruise
i will not join even if he came to your
house and was like i love you man i'm a
big fan i don't know that's i'm not
trying to do a tom cruise impression but
i know what i'm saying
i'm also a big tom cruise fan too that's
fair that would help he is great tom
cruise thank you for the sovereignty
i mean here's the thing people like to
talk [ __ ] about tom cruise because he's
crazy on interviews and the
scientologist
i don't think he's done more than one
bad movie he mo 99 percent of this
because
we're the most consistent the most
consistent when it comes to making films
those mission impossibles people go
crazy for every time they're all good
and here's the thing they're not corny
whereas like when you look at uh
uh fast
oh fast and furious
are horrible yeah
they're terrible when you look at those
like it it gets really corny whenever
the diesel movie comes out everyone's
like i don't think i'm gonna see that
yeah
unless you're in china then he's a star
yeah yeah absolutely
his top gun movie already came out right
uh mavericks
what day is it and
you know what i bet they gave him all
the rain like or like or like gave him
all the [ __ ] free reign free reign or
whatever that movie has been delayed for
years
okay yeah like
yeah and i bet it's gonna i bet it's
gonna do good
what is the one bad movie he has though
do you have that in mind
i don't
but i there's god it was probably a
movie that he he wasn't he didn't do ooh
last samurai was so good last time was
great i have not contacted him and
tropic thunder was really good oh he's
amazing
yeah is there something night and day
maybe that i don't think that did very
well was that cam diaz
yeah that's probably better yeah look at
its imdb rating but did he did he do
that movie did he make that movie six
point three that's not bad six point
three isn't bad yeah imdb has the
weirdest scale that's six point three
you're like oh that's pretty good you
know yeah they just can't get into
eights on imdb if it's eight it's really
you know what he does his own stunts
[Music]
bro he he's chilling on the airplane
while it's flying he's dated really hot
girls in his past nicole kidman yeah
nicole kidman yeah you don't really
katie you know i respect him because i i
feel like he kind of just keeps to
himself he stays in his world and he
does his he does exactly what the [ __ ]
he wants i respect any any celebrity
that like he doesn't seem like he's like
out and about
just [ __ ] you know like hey look at
me i'm tom cruise he seems like he keeps
to himself and meanwhile he just lets
all his work [ __ ] do the talking i
love people like that there's a lot of
tick tocks of people pretending to be
him with the filters and it looks really
real but it's really funny yeah he also
might be gay which is kind of cool we
don't know his sexuality a lot of gay
people think he's gay you got kids
yeah that doesn't mean anything
that could be a beer
ellen john has kids yeah that's true
you're right okay i feel like tom cruise
is one of the last people in the older
class of hollywood where they were
famous and they had a mystique about
them because you didn't really know much
now i feel like when you're a celebrity
everyone knows everything everyone knows
everything about you that's why i love
guys like denzel oh yeah he's great same
one say the same like like he keeps
doing serious mysterious but he says the
most prolific [ __ ] whenever he's asked a
question and i'm like holy [ __ ] this guy
just [ __ ] he also tom cruise hasn't
been canceled that i know of probably
the last celebrity that hasn't been
canceled that's pretty cool no i don't
think scientology will allow it right
they keep him too shelter
which is why i feel like you should join
yeah john
me and uh abby roberge used to go to the
church of scientology all the time the
one in north hollywood no the one on
sunset the big blue one the big one just
walk in and [ __ ] around well that's like
almost close to like silver lake and all
that [ __ ]
yeah right there one time we brought in
a bunch of little caesars and they liked
us forever after that but then good to
know i've been thinking about doing this
for a bit for a podcast i didn't know
how much like how dangerous they don't
let you in too far you have to they want
you to the whole time you're there you
pay trying to get yeah they're trying to
pay you to um they're trying to get you
to pay to take their classes
you take this test no no that's the
celebrity center the regular one you
take a
a test about your a personality test
that you call it
and they they sit you down they go
so uh it looks like you're a really
smart guy and you go thank you yeah but
i could see that they find your weakness
right because you you answer all these
questions and it's probably real they're
like i could see you're not that
motivated and you go yeah i'm not you
know we have a class on how to get
motivated it's 150 dollars would really
help you out and that's their
it's almost like a
a producer of a reality show you know
like they'll like get you
like they get stuff that's how you get
the drama out of those people during the
confessionals you know what i'm saying
like how they kind of like
bait you in a way
to like find out the thing that is a
triggering thing for you yeah by saying
certain things like oh you know deborah
or whatever whoever the [ __ ] on those
damn shows debra you know she was kind
of looking at you crazy when yeah
expressing how you feel about it yeah
and you're like she was yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're talking you know what and
then all of a sudden you start letting
out [ __ ] about deborah that you've never
let out before yeah you know what i mean
like that's what i feel like that's like
that's why i love the challenges i love
them and then afterwards they compete
and beat each other's asses
on one of those shows oh my god that's
literally my dream from childhood do you
apply huh do you apply for that no i
don't i think they should i yeah
you have to be part of that cast yeah
the challenge is a hard cookie to crack
i could definitely see you in another
amazing race yeah amazing race what do
you do on amazing race is it it's
actually the same thing
uh you have a partner right yeah you go
with a partner and it's just you start
in one city in america and you have to
get someplace else i don't know the
restrictions like there's travel and you
have to do it yourself and it's like a
scavenger hunt an epic scavenger hunt
and like oh i feel like i'd get lost do
a lot of obstacles
i think so i think that's part of it is
it's amazing race and i've seen that
video where the lady was trying to
slingshot the [ __ ] watermelon
like viral we don't like watermelon as
much as you do though
it's actually water because i [ __ ]
don't like i love water
there's a lot of edits where they'll
like keep putting it back in her face i
hope this is the right one but this is
the one yeah watch don't give up on me
now please just focus
she just thinks everything's going her
way
oh my god this is going to hurt to watch
isn't it oh god
oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh i was like oh this
isn't the one and then you come back
oh my god
it hurts to show if she's okay like that
would that cause serious damage i think
it would i guess it would break open
maybe yeah i think it already broke i
think it broke open before like oh yeah
you will see it explode
damn
oh my god
that's good tv
that is great tv
but i think this is part of the amazing
race
yeah i know i can't do that
because i've watched this video so many
[ __ ] times that that's real you can't
you can't you can't fake that
that kind of reaction look at her home
girl
i want to see the after
i forget what happens after
what if uh they wiped her face off
are you okay what if they wipe her face
off right now
it's just a black coming to help her
tonight coming to [ __ ] help you like
hey you good give me a doctor
okay so what do we do now
what
yes this is amazing so you want cat to
do that yeah yeah oh my god
i mean yeah i'd love to see her do that
watermelon stunt
[Laughter]
i think i would get the same result i
would like to do that
that looks so fun slingshotting the
things i obviously wouldn't want it to
happen
like
oh it probably would probably would
probably happen is it just
wrapped up yeah yeah it just probably
just didn't release out of that [ __ ]
but man it's just [ __ ] pictures do
they have those at medieval times or
like the like renaissance fair that they
have like like these slingshot things
i've been to the one in anaheim me too
uh i went for mother's day like five
years ago oh is your mom into that or
are you into it uh
i don't think either of us are into it
but it sounded fun it was fun i remember
i went i got drunk just for a good time
i drink that often i went with my
brother and my mom we went to them and
they put you on a team and you root for
your night yeah yeah
but no they didn't have that month ago a
month ago why'd you go uh just because
uh jules is she's like live within miles
from in her entire life and she was like
i've never been and i was like this
sounds [ __ ] dope what and it's pretty
fun right yeah yeah it's for kids
no uh medieval medieval times oh yeah
they just have and you know what's crazy
is they do two shows a night uh a late
show and an early show
400 people sold out on a wednesday at 6
00 p.m it made me be like like the
comics can't sell rooms and [ __ ] i'm
like people are coming to this i mean
it's majestic and there's a lot of
production there's a huge it's probably
[ __ ] 50 people working on it yeah big
cast they probably get i was [ __ ]
juggling on stage every night i think
i'd be selling some damn tickets yeah
you do backflips
but the juggling will the the juggling
will you know like you got to do some
[ __ ] magical [ __ ] i can only do the
backflip one time
i can juggle for an hour well you got to
learn well i've never learned how to
jump yeah you gotta learn how to juggle
and then you have a backup career too
then if you're a stand-up comedy fail
you could join the medieval times
they probably make what 30 bucks an hour
you think and you're always
you think you'll start out as a king or
you have to work your way up to the
ranks
i'll start out as a king because i'm
black and they want to be like hey we
need to yeah like hey kings never had a
lot of white kings
and this guy
listen we got to give it to him
we're in our obama era even even though
i would suck as a king they'd be like
hey
it's very real thing that they're
probably gonna do because they had the
same story for the first 40 years of
medieval times it was a king but in 2017
they switched the story and i went and
there was a queen
instead of a king so black
have you ever seen the black knight
yeah with martin lawrence yeah i love
that
classic yep i feel like i don't even
want to watch it now because it was
probably horrible but when i was a kid
it was good i mean i haven't seen it
recently either but i think it will hold
up i think it would hold up i watched it
when i was a kid yeah i watched it as an
adult i was like damn i should have done
that see that's what i'm saying i bet
you it was awful yeah i kind of regret
that yeah
i was like [ __ ]
such a good movie i was uh talking to
someone that had worked on that movie
and they're like it would have it would
have hit which i didn't realize this
about movies and
this whole world or whatever like
industry
it would have hit but it was just the
timing of when they had put it out and
they put it out the same weekend as
another really big comedy like a
blockbuster film like a big blockbuster
film i didn't realize that movie didn't
hit in my mind that was a hit
exactly yeah but i mean you look at the
results
you can tell martin lawrence is doing
all right though he's doing fine yeah
he's doing okay dude you know he what he
was he was [ __ ] making bank on movies
i think he was blue streak dude blue
streak oh
that holds up someone tells me they
didn't like that now there's two of
those or three just one i think there's
a second but martin lawrence isn't in it
oh okay there's the second blue string
wait blue streaks martin lawrence and
will smith right no blue that's bad boys
oh singing a bad boy
luke uh look luke what the [ __ ] is
wilson luke wilson okay uh dave
chappelle's in it oh nice yeah i
remember everyone that was good too
oh yeah
skinny [ __ ] dave chappelle skinny dave
chappelle yeah
okay there's no blue streak too yeah i
think well there should be yeah yeah you
heard it here first blue streak wait so
hey back to the west virginia
[ __ ] you haven't seen them no
with the eyes
man type in and some of the men hook up
with each other
no that's what stevie told me
the men in in the in the uh inbred
family because like everyone just kind
of [ __ ] each other i guess nick you
would have to type in west virgin west
virginia inbred family
a million things pop up
they're like which one you're like
average family
uh welcome george hi george
people what's up doctor george is cute
huh cute
at one point i thought ari mantis was
meatball's brother when i saw you and
theo at the ryman during his netflix
taping and i was very high and dm'd
christian was like i didn't know you had
a gay brother he's like i do but like i
don't oh you know
no you ari has a joke in his uh stand-up
brother
so you thought there was a third brother
yeah i thought there was another one or
three boys
i think you told us about this the first
time you're on here yeah wait did you
type it in yeah but it's just i am not
you're plugged in so it'll go up on the
screen um you can just drag it over it
it goes to the right
option there they are there they are yup
that's fine the one on the far left he
barks that guy that guy he bargained
you've seen this old guy yeah
yeah crazy
yeah he has to do a whole like i just
photographed the whittaker family for my
first week created equal in 2004 that
was interrupted by an angry neighbor
with a shotgun who threatened to use it
if i didn't leave the whittakers alone
after explaining what i was doing he
calmed down and allowed me to photograph
the whitaker family the two portraits
shown in this video are from that book
i've returned to visit the whitaker's
when i've been in appalachia for other
shoots but on this visit in july of 2020
i recorded a bit of video
of something many of us
have heard of but never actually seen i
strongly discourage anyone from
attempting to look at the whitakers as
their our neighbors and the raleigh
county deputies both make it clear that
curious visitors are not so that means
their neighbors really like them and
defend them yeah defend their honor
that's nice yeah god there was a guy and
i can't remember soft white underbelly
mm-hmm that's what it's called that's
also my uh nickname on tinder so
there we go there you go look it watch
you see
i zoomed it up a little bit so if you
want me to slow it down one in the
orange shirt barks i have seen this so
you have seen this this is awesome yeah
do we want so you can't be inbred
well i'm not like this that's for sure
i think there are different levels
you think your mom and dad are like
somewhat related
my mom and dad aren't cousins or
anything i just wonder if back in the
day like if it's a long line of inbred
how far back do you think yeah if you
were in bread how far back in the
christmas days got it jesus
maybe that's like why we have bigger
noses i don't know
why do jewish people have bigger noses
you don't have a big nose but it's above
average you're not at my angle
listen i don't have the biggest i have a
wide nose okay i've been told i have a
big nose my entire life yeah what kind
of nose do i have ari
[Music]
no comment
i'm not i'm not falling for that trap
little baby you got a cute nose
i just want to touch noses with you
but i don't know i think that's a crazy
interesting story but i remember the the
uh
the whites
yeah that family
they were ahead of the game the opiates
i mean uh they were because that was
like what er that was early 2000s yeah
yeah
the opiates didn't well no opiates were
early 2000s okay yeah no they were
around that time the what was it called
the wonderful whites yeah of west
virginia i'm crazy you ever heard of the
wonderful whites of west virginia are
they
like these
dragons
uh if you press escape option j yeah uh
have you ever done opiates no never what
about anyone here no no it's [ __ ]
everything scares me opiates are just
isn't a vicodin's considered an opiate
have you done vicodin nope
dude i remember when i got my wisdom
teeth out um
they gave me that [ __ ] and i just
[ __ ] threw it in the toilet damn
you're tough yeah i was like [ __ ] i
don't need this [ __ ] you take a nice
muscle relaxer before bed hell enough
have a ice cream bar that's a good night
i'm scared of nyquist for me nyquil does
that for me that's as far as i can go
nyquist not cool [ __ ] i forgot all
night close like tylenol doesn't really
do much it doesn't do anything for you
not me bro whenever i've taken nyquil i
just know i always wake up so [ __ ]
like i feel like i'm hungover we were
asked to be quieter
a little bit oh sorry to indoor voices
i'll cut that out but
you're going to ruin the flow
nyquil's crazy
[Laughter]
let me tell you about nyquil i took one
last night you did yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ]
me up
i love it i love trying to stay awake
while on nyquil because i'm such a like
i have zero tolerance for anything so
the moment i take nyquil i just try to
stay awake and i feel that's as close as
i will ever truly feel to being high
because i think i smoked weed like two
or three times in my life and i didn't
do it right i don't think i actually got
high yeah i think i was in my head and
thought i was high and got really
anxious want to huh uh maybe not today
thank you though i was just kidding oh i
thought i thought that would get a laugh
now we're all [ __ ]
tamped down
yeah who wanted us to be quiet they're
filming a food truck out there god oh
god i got it i didn't know about that
though type of wonderful family of
whites
or wonderful white family or whatever
those are the best kinds of families
from my life
yeah
wonderful yeah wonderful families yeah
yeah where were you where was
you're from a white family right
i'm not from a white family but were you
not raised by a white family not
yeah all right then yeah point in case
is that the right expression yeah say i
know my expressions that's not where i'm
from
it's not where you were born yeah i
can't be born into a white family
i think you can i just don't think you
were not scientifically
i was going to say i don't see color but
you're not supposed to say that anymore
apparently that's racist now to say i
don't see color because then you're
ignoring their um struggle yeah as a
black man what's the okay term to say
struggle
yeah like what's the modern day i don't
see color
i don't think there is one because yeah
by saying i don't see color
is saying i'm ignoring your struggles as
a black man well i do think it's an odd
thing to say i don't see color well it's
obviously [ __ ] too it's obviously
totally boring but you're meaning you
don't treat people differently yeah i
think and i think people when they say
that i think they mean well i think they
mean well exactly that's why you're
stupid
i think they mean well it's just a very
weird thing to say because like oh i
don't see color it's like [ __ ] yeah you
do i've always said it as a joke every
time it happens
it's more funny as a [ __ ] joke now
yeah the the super woke thing is to like
look at people and only solely define
them on their race
like that's woke
oh really yeah it's like the opposite of
what he said is that really pretty much
yes like people are only it's weird
because it's like
i know i just can't keep up with all
this [ __ ] and i'm not going to and i'm
sorry that easy for you to say you know
it's just a lot you know i mean i've had
people say things to me
as a black person where i'm just like
just [ __ ] leave me alone well you
know they don't have any ill will when
they say it but you're like shut up it
was just when people are just trying to
be so
um well extra careful yeah with how they
talk to me are they trying to shield you
from racism when you did it
yeah yeah like
i remember one time i was at fourth wall
the fourth wall is just open mic you pay
five dollars you pay five dollars to go
up or whatever blah blah it you know
that's where i've worked out a lot of
stuff yeah it serves his purpose
but like fourth wall is known as the mic
that's like
the [ __ ]
not a lot of great people are going up
in there
well you're they're just you're never
gonna have like a real audience you're
never gonna have a real audience and
it's just always weird the energy's
weird but i love it i'm like i it's
because it's very gritty but i remember
one time uh
i was doing this mic
and this guy
was kept he he dropped in white dude
dropped the n-bomb like five times
er no
uh
no not not hard r chicken yeah
dropped a hard r like five times in a
set and he's and the joke was like his
friend jamal
said he could say which i knew he was
lying because i was like you don't have
a friend named jamal
i was like [ __ ] i was like you're
like 20 something that's like you know
[ __ ] 20 something year old dude named
jamal now
jamal's over with yeah [ __ ] jamal's
like 40 now okay
jamal is [ __ ] he's high up in age but
i remember
i remember being at that mic and all
these white people [ __ ] just went up
and at this dude
and like i didn't even get to say
anything to the dude or whatever but
they just all went up like yo you need
to not [ __ ] do that
like just going at this dude
and then you know he like
it was weird because he couldn't really
i don't think he gave a [ __ ] when they
said anything and i just looked down and
i said hey man i was like all i said was
this i said hey do what you want but i
was like here's the thing i said you're
lucky you got me
i was like you lucky i was in the
audience yeah i was like i don't speak
for every black person but i was like
there's one that will [ __ ] you up for
that i was like you're lucky you got me
i ain't trying to fight nobody i'm not
trying to hit you i don't want to hit
you i don't i don't hurt you but you're
lucky you got me you know and then he
understood but that but it was just
funny like how they just like teamed up
on them and it was like they were trying
to
i hate even saying this but it was like
they were trying to show off in front of
me that they weren't
with they they're not racist
they're not they're not looking at you
while they said it they're like
disciplining him and they're like you
see that
yeah man and this is why you shouldn't
say it because uh
you know just but yeah it is it does it
don't it's i don't know in a weird way
it is uncomfortable
you know but whatever it's [ __ ] i get
this just life can i just live my life
can i just [ __ ]
just let me exist and why
just not the times
that's what happened you're the cool guy
right now being the black guy is the
coolest guy to be right now no he wasn't
cool but right now i wish i was a black
guy oh do you really i so wish i would
have so that's why you wanted to join
the nation of islam so what would you do
as a black guy if you first off black
guy is gay yeah what yeah what's your
name
yeah realize you're 32 yeah come on well
it couldn't be
because i don't want to be a jewish
black guy that's weird and they exist
but like jake drake yeah yeah yeah yeah
well he's half black right yeah half
black i want to i don't want to be half
black i'm going all the way okay okay
all right well i'm not i don't have
facts so are you sure you want to so is
jamal your final answer for your name
yeah i want to be jamal bringing it it's
unique what's your middle name black
people got middle names and we got fun
ones shut up
what's your middle name what's your
middle name
there's a lot of people without middle
names always what's your middle name you
know it
i do it's lacey
what's your last name man harris i
didn't know that you didn't know that i
don't know i now remember oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay so i want mine but i
got it i don't know we did talk about
this we did because you told me about um
your real last name oh right and like
the name change or whatever and i got
the paperwork for my
name change or whatever so you did you
were legitimate literally
yes so i want my middle name to be lazy
then jamal
go with what you know i know you
the only one of my brothers his middle
name is uh deshante caiman
so that's your brother's name yes so you
can be jamal deshante hyman manus i'd
rather be lazy i think what about the
coldest the coldest yeah what about the
golden coldest there's like there's this
football recruit that went viral because
his name was dakota
so
i don't want to funny listen i'm telling
you yeah okay this isn't a joke because
i'm because it's your life because i
want to know i wonder how black you want
to be i want to be all the way back okay
i don't want to have that all right so
so we got his name obviously yeah we
have his first name where's his first
name jamal jamal
where does jamal
live
uh you could live anywhere these days if
you're black i feel like except arkansas
is a smart guy yeah there's no more
redlining it's fine yeah maybe i heard
arkansas is the most racist state in the
country is it that's what i heard
i'd probably avoid i'm sure there's
still black people there but i'd
probably not want to be in the middle of
the razorbacks
yeah i don't know so i'd probably
razorbacks are racist i think i'd stay
in l.a i'd want to be somewhere woke and
here's why because right you would want
to be somewhere woke yeah because so
even though i'm not woke as a white guy
i would be really woke as a black guy
because right now
as a woke black
you're getting jobs okay
you're getting white [ __ ] okay which is
the best kind of [ __ ] i mean that's
debatable yeah yeah you've probably
never been with a black girl so how do
you know that uh i've been with them
yeah i've been with them yeah oh [ __ ]
is that their pronouns what i just got
caught up in anyways i can say that i'm
black guy now all right jamal okay yeah
you're jamal i'm jamal so i could say
that yeah jamal in l.a oh yeah i should
set us up you've been with us jamal's
walking around l.a
okay so do you have pronouns he's
getting all the jobs different i'd still
be you know how do you keep him yeah how
does jamal dress well that's a tough one
do you wear vape
do i vape do you wear vape what's vape
streetwear brand like the uh you see tim
dillon decked out and like in vape in
like yeah tim dylan's rock this this
you've seen it oh i've seen that i never
knew that what that was called yeah it's
like the style tim don't like the way
that's like a good street
it's hilarious maybe i'd be skater black
okay
he's got like this like gq style crazy
crazy hats
no i don't wanna i'm not but
see that's athlete jamal not an athlete
i'd say i'd say yeah skater athlete i've
always wanted to be an athlete and if
you're not like cam newton perform
better what's that skateboarder's name
the uh
niger houston niger houston would you be
like that too he's cool is he is he full
black no i think he's mixed i think he's
my job
i think his dad's yes dad's black dude
have you seen
have you guys seen naija houston
josh uh what's this yeah josh nasser
yeah video i feel bad for that josh
nassar tried to bury this but i could
bring it up because josh nasser hates my
guts so i don't know he does
listen hey okay so here's why josh
nasser hates me and i feel like i'm
talking too much on this podcast
you're a guest but is is nasser is he a
comic that you guys know or who is yes
yeah
to update the audience and to you josh
nasser is a comic he's a paid regular at
the comedy store he's passed by mitzi
shore i want to say his videos do really
good on uh
tick-tock yeah he doesn't really have
the comedy story no like he does like
funny like
he has
a really popular tic toc account and
he's it's him in the car and he pulls up
to people
and he gets them rolled down their
windows and he gives them really nice
compliments yeah so he'll get like a
woman troll then i went and goes hey uh
why are you so beautiful or something
like things like that but it's cuter and
funnier funny videos it's great yeah i
follow all the comedy clubs in like
hollywood i look at the lions all the
time he doesn't get spots oh okay
because i've never seen his name yeah
and i'm surprised he doesn't now because
he blew up on tick tock he has like oh
yeah
his instagram's doing really well so
anyways um because he was blowing up on
tick tock that and he shoots all the
videos with an iphone i believe
he posted on his facebook hey i'm
looking to upgrade my setup i want to
buy a camera
i'm a gear nerd i have a bunch of tech
as you guys know so i was like i'll sell
you one of my old cameras
so he came over to buy the camera
and he left and oh and while he was
buying the camera he was this was at
when trump and biden were running
against each other and he was telling me
how he doesn't talk to his family
anymore because they're trump supporters
so he like hates him and he disowned his
family
so i saw him the camera he forgot the
charger to it so next day i texted him i
was like hey you forgot the charger if
you want to come by and get it and i
ended the text with hashtag trump2024.
yeah
joking right yeah joking clearly a joke
okay
because he told me because he told me
how he hate how he disowned his family
and you were just i'm just poking fun
whatever and that's you and that's me
you're also comics we're also both
comedians that is good that's your style
that's very so his response to that
was
that's not funny i i told you i don't
talk to my family anymore because of
trump i don't think that's funny
and if you know me
i'm not
[Music]
i'm not canadian you know i'll stand up
for myself so
you better not give me a ride back to
hollywood
so so he says that's not funny so my
response to that was
well you can still call your family and
apologize and maybe they'll forgive you
and then his response to that was
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] dick i don't need
the charger die die die [ __ ] you die
like crazy prisons just like
of course you saved it
no i i could pull it up yeah it was [ __ ]
you die die die talking all this [ __ ]
and i was like are you okay and he's
like i'm [ __ ] fine [ __ ] you i'm
blocking you blocks me on everything now
every time i see him like at the comment
store i go up to him
and i'm like really nice i'm like hey
josh good to see you and he just ignores
me completely completely ignores me
uh so that's my that's why he hates
dale that's why i hate speech but going
back to his niger because he buried this
and i'm trying to bring it back because
he hates me
so i'm super excited to hear his story
so before he was famous on social media
this is when he was an un complete
unknown comic i would say
my level of fame which is not fame at
all no no success do you feel like
you're at a tipping point are you like
no i feel like i'm
anyways oh i want to be negative i'm i'm
doing great but
so when he was at an uh when he was an
unknown
he uh was driving in his car out of a
parking structure and nija the famous
skateboarder was skating down hollywood
boulevard and his camera guy behind him
making an escape video and he's skating
by josh nasser's car just
because josh was pulling out josh out he
was skating and he i think he just
tapped it he left he gives his josh's
car like a lovely to say like hey i'm
skating by he wasn't you it's on video
he's not like uh
trying to [ __ ] up josh's car he doesn't
hit a heart he just like taps it like
hey come by don't don't hit me basically
and uh josh gets livid pissed that
doesn't sound like him from everything
he rolls down
yeah he flips out on naija and he's like
what the [ __ ] do you think you're doing
and he ends up calling him a gay f word
oh oh i thought i was like there's
nothing
saying his name
went to jail that like look at so
there's
here's the video
go back a little bit george can you i
think it's coming up right now
um
yeah right here right here right here
melody he almost ran them over right
here
um so he just tapped it like so yeah you
could see just make him aware like yeah
which like i get it like that's
extremely inappropriate homophobic words
and um later calls are cops they go to
jail etc um i made a video about it
jesus
so yeah
yeah he calls him a yeah they the f-word
yells at him calls the cops on them and
then naija uploads his video to his
instagram
and they find out someone in the
comments like this is comedian josh
nasser and guess what
his fans went nuts on josh like dude
josh had a show that night
and they showed up to the show i didn't
even hear you yeah you know that he had
a show at the hollywood improv
and they
did not let him live on stage he had to
delete all social media it went crazy oh
yeah how long how long would you say
that was like 2018 yeah
yeah 2018. that's why
do you think his tic tacks of
complimenting people he's just trying to
atone
i think it blew over i think i think it
blew up he deleted his social media he
when tick tock came out he he came back
on and now i don't think really he just
blew that i'm trying yeah i'm trying to
bring it back since he hates me yeah
yeah yeah i'm down but how much would it
do if you bring it back i'm just kidding
well i don't know i think it depends on
where you bring it back if you brought
it back on tick tock where he's popular
then that's where i actually now that
it's now that i'm saying it out loud i
feel bad i don't know i don't want it
bro no no no no i don't want it i'm not
trying to ruin this guy he could he's
crazy enough on his own he'll ruin [ __ ]
for himself i don't he doesn't need me
to ruin it but
sorry that's fair we could keep the last
20 minutes in all right yeah that was
jamal
that wasn't all right that was this was
all ari
no it's jamal so oh yeah it's jamal
jamal ari has a thing to do with it so
when did jamal transition over yeah
you know just now because all i know is
that you still haven't told us how you
dress you don't you didn't tell us like
you either skate or anything you didn't
tell us where you're at
does jamal live in silver lake yeah i'm
in a woke area i'm either a professional
skater or athlete because i've got black
man talent now so i can do it okay
jamal's top two favorite artists
uh artist like music artist yeah damn
this is so hard what is german bricks
okay
and lupe this is a skater
lupita uh
i hate you so far you don't like jimi
hendrix i love jimmy hendricks
how do you think that's what jamal was
gonna say dude
i thought
like jimmy hendrix i just i thought you
were gonna say something maybe uh who's
the first uh black baseball player
jackie robinson yeah he was the first
black baseball player in the mlb yeah
right right that's what i meant mlb in
the mlb obviously
yeah i'd say jackie robinson jimi
hendrix
i feel like i would really get along
with jamal when we did backyard
wrestling on trampolines when i was in
middle school i came out to jimi hendrix
purple haze
oh so you and jamal already have a
connection jamie hendricks a legend and
jamal so versatile
without harley you get along with
everybody jamal gets along with
everybody
jamal is a renaissance man yeah he's a
renaissance yeah okay all right jamal
and lacy mannis oh man i wish i just
this got me thinking i just wish i was a
black guy
i really do
if i could wake up like parent trap is
that the movie yeah yeah and i could
wake up tomorrow and we switch places
i'd never give it back no no freaky
friday yeah
friday yeah breaking free friday's the
movie you're thinking about yeah i'd
never give you your body back you
wouldn't like the chris brown little
dickie song you really wouldn't give you
like if i was like hey i need my [ __ ]
yeah i'd be like sorry i need my black
dangling back
you're stuck in that jewel dude
you think
today before 2 30. i could jump high
you can do backflip i do backflips yeah
i [ __ ] i can skate
i can [ __ ] play guitar i can do all
the dope as [ __ ] yeah you have reflexes
you swing at me you don't have the
sniffles one day a week yeah that was
good yeah see
i don't have allergies yeah yeah you
don't get sick every three months with a
cold like you're like good dude i don't
drive a previous this would be good i
gave up the prius i have a pickup truck
now oh i don't drive a
along those lines but what's up with the
van i got the vans all done
and you have you uh traveled
this is embarrassing i finished it like
two months ago
i've only spent one night in it
but
this is just like a travel van i built a
camper van over the pandemic so bed
shower sink
let me rent it you could drive for free
um so
yeah of course uh but but only if you
could have this body only if i could
have
that black dick dude you want this black
digger
i just want it from what sounds like a
very cheap version of get out when
they're like auctioning off the black
bodies to switch over you're like if you
if i give you my van fortune
it's not even the fact that it's a
jewish body it's just your body
specifically
i'll take the curly hair i'll [ __ ] with
that you got a little same hair you
already have yeah right
great point little corey matthews couple
already i have yeah fro
and i get ashy
oh you get ashy yeah i got ashy so we're
gonna have a pretty big day is there is
so
the black jewish community there's a lot
of black jews right
no there's not a lot but there's a
couple
like
another one but uh and they're like
traditional like orthodox uh i've never
met an orthodox black jew looking at
like people like me
my level your level okay
and yeah it's weird every time is it but
they exist i don't yeah i don't know how
it works if one of their distant
relatives was born into it i don't know
how it became black jews i mean like
there's dark jews
what's crazy about you is that like you
have a darker tone to you so like you
can't tell that i'm just tan
but they're so i'm i'm uh what's it
called ashkenazi that's the white kind
of jews and then there's middle eastern
jews which are basically brown jews
there's a lot of brown juice
but not a lot of black jews
got it yeah yeah so we need to be up in
there yeah yeah represent so how do i
get up in there
i don't know diversify that i don't want
to get involved you don't need that
you're doing good i'm doing good yeah
yeah you're sure
okay all right
well you don't need to be jamal then
[ __ ]
but i want it i don't need it but i want
it you want it hey
would you would you be black if you
could be oh yeah
i like growing up like
i think it's because it's just economics
but like i was i was a black kid i loved
hit by music i played basketball
uh
those are the two things but see you
your area was predominantly white yeah
yeah la crosse wisconsin
oh yeah come on now but you had some
black friends you seemed like you were a
kid in high school that would kick it
with black people
like i went to private school we had one
kid and i was friends with him okay uh
amos
shout out to amy shout out to amy i love
famous
famous amos cookies yeah baby
you're just claiming everything for
black yeah yeah
i also it was like you they were just in
my area there was not a lot of black but
you're from san diego yeah and i'm from
del mar there was same with you there's
like two black people in my whole high
school really uh i went to a military
school for my first two years of high
school
and that was very diverse there was a
lot of mexicans and blacks but it was
very uh segregated all the mexicans kept
to themselves the black people kept
themselves prison rules yeah yeah it was
prison rules but there was no like fight
so there was always race fights but they
kept themselves because of all the
discipline
we know yeah
oh yeah yeah interesting time it's
politicking yeah haven't you seen 60
days in
um my boy abner have you ever seen 60s
ladies and gentlemen you've educated me
a lot today a lot of things i know the
wonderful whites and breads
you're [ __ ] you're jamal too jamal
now jamal you transformed me i know
this is so funny
we need to find someone to
scientifically get us to do the freaky
friday thing so we can switch for
an hour or so he's gonna rob you of your
body like you're not getting it back oh
he's gonna oh he's gonna go you think
you're gonna be able to fight ari in
your body off with you and his body i
know that blackface is not okay and i
would never do it in today's yes age
even as a joke it's just it's past its
time you can't do it anymore it's like
the n word there's never a case that
where it's okay
but
one day technology is going to evolve
to where it's not just like black makeup
you could straight up just turn yourself
into a black guy and it looks real and
legit mm-hmm and then i feel like
it's okay to do if you want to be a
black guy and actually convert yourself
to one it'll be okay so you think so you
think the way people transition from
male to female female to male yeah you
think they'll be due white to black yeah
there will be some laser machine people
do that with eight with asians i feel
like there's a lot of white people who
are really into like asian culture who
transitioned to asia very quickly
i feel like you could go from like
wants to be asian i feel like it rings a
bell but there's a white british dude he
basically got the surgery to make
himself oh his name is ollie white ollie
white yeah i would not want to be asian
no i think being an asian girl is fine
being an asian guy is a little rough
depending on oh being an asian guy
sounds like the worst person to be all
he wants you're like
have you seen what's his name ross
butler and
no
there's there's this one like really hot
asian like actor dude who i think like
that's the model asian guy everyone
thinks is hot but now with people
enjoying uh
yes
now with the rise of people loving kpop
i feel like this is the time to be an
asian man if there was ever a time i
don't think it's there yet here's the
thing asian guys i don't know if we've
talked about this before i don't think
being an asian guy
is the only race where even asian girls
are like i don't date asian guys
really there's a lot of asian girls
obviously not every asian girl but yeah
you're right for no other questions
people where the girls are like that i
don't date my own race but in american
asians at least there's plenty of asian
girls they're like i don't date asian
guys really yeah and that's
hard yeah oh that'd be hard to be i
thought if somebody been wanting to ask
ari for a really really long time can
you uh
that's the asian one uh
unlicensed therapy nick davis
can you change out my thumbnail
yeah
why what is like the picture i posted on
my instagram you could have texted this
but yeah i know but i just it felt so it
felt so like let's see i don't remember
what it is
that looks like the oldest yeah headshot
of you yeah all right that's the guy i
want to be right there
that version i'll take that back he's
gonna lose ten pounds or command plus
command you don't like that
are were you mad at me no you already
why would you do this like i look like
[ __ ] that day i don't know what the [ __ ]
was going on
it's definitely not your most flattering
it's not that bad
what are you doing i feel like you
[ __ ] the numbers on that episode
everybody's like i'm not gonna watch
this for an hour and a half 6.8 for me
is a lot that's good numbers for me
world shows if you like cheap okay i'll
be honest i'll come back i'll tell you
i'll tell you how that that thumbnail
came to be it wasn't me if i'm being
honest i went on fiverr and i paid a guy
to redo all my thumbnails and he just
made them all and did that one so i'll
change it uh could i get his contact
info
i just might hire him
i remembered
that
it literally
it literally looks like ari picked you
up at a bar
one time theo his first ever guest was
uh some homeless guy he met at the dmv
uneven stephen that's what i look like
i think you look cute dude yeah that's
insane shut up
[Laughter]
it's jamal are you not like me
sorry jamal it's jamal
uh that's good take it down take it down
[Laughter]
see that was already that would do that
jamal would never jamal would never
jamal will have you looking fly jamal
would have sent you a thumbnail for
approval before he posted it yeah
small couldn't afford to go on fiverr
[Music]
what is that like
it's like uh it used to be five dollars
now there's hard to get something for
five dollars because everyone can set
their prices we'll just find freelancers
and they can't do anything and they have
ratings oh got it it's like a graphic
almost like a
task rabbit kind of but yeah but for
digital digital stuff yeah there was a
trend on youtube for a while where
people send uh different editors on
fiverr like a random photo of them say
hey will you edit this photo for me and
you get to see like what someone else
would think your like ideal look would
be oh that's like they're funny they
don't make like the funny they're like
my hands look too big sometimes yeah
that too like oh my boyfriend has the
phone in the photo can you actually take
it out and it's like in a large photo of
them in their boyfriend's hands yes
graphic artists video editors music
creators it's cool it's cool that's
though
well good for you ari
i mean jamal well no that's alright
that's a hardy thing
oh gosh wow shout out to the that's the
asian man
that's why he was healing i wonder what
he looks like now because i don't think
that looks like an asian man that looks
more like melania trump botched to me
watch do you guys watch it a lot batched
no i used to every now and then but i
haven't watched any of that recently
i love watching it and it's just people
talking about how terrible their
experiences are
and then they get fixed afterwards it's
so satisfying that's his first picture
because i know the producer of bots
would be interesting to talk to him but
that would be a good guess is there any
as a female is there any pressure for
you do you want to get plastic surgery
of any sort i feel like every girl in
l.a wants one plastic surgery i feel
like it's so normalized now where it's
almost like oh why not do it if you want
something changed about yourself and you
have the money and resources but i'm
really afraid of going under
i'm scared that i'm going to go under
not wake up
that's that's one of my biggest fears so
no you're not getting i'm not opposed to
it though like maybe one day i'll change
my mind
uh every now and then like
i would love to try the lip fillers just
to see what everybo what the fuss is all
about you have to go under for those
yeah and you don't have to go under but
my
boyfriend stevie is so adamantly opposed
to it because he says when you kiss
someone with filler doesn't feel like a
rubber does it really yeah and it i
thought he was just [ __ ] around
because he doesn't want me to get
anything you notice it feels good when
they're giving you a head but not
kissing yeah isn't it what does it feel
like when they're giving you head and
there's like oh like there's pillows
wrapped around okay just like more plump
yeah it's nice but overall i don't like
them the other thing that i think is
scary
the girls getting lip filler is so when
you get the first time you probably just
get a little bit and it looks okay it
looks cute whatever addiction but then
you get used to that look and the next
time you go you get them bigger and you
don't notice it because you look at
yourself every day but then all of a
sudden you come out like that
and you think you're looking pretty
normal and everyone around you is like
duck lips it's your fine ass right
that's my theory i was also told the
more lip filler you get and the more
often you start to lose the color in
your lips so girls would then go get
their lips tattooed to be the original
color of their lips wait go back go back
to kylie
it's like our nation's tax code
so can you tell what kylie did to
well she clearly got lip fillers
that's the only thing i could tell kylie
jenner okay
that's wild
it just looks like her lips are bigger
right
in that photo yeah but she looks
different now as a was she like 24. i
don't mind thin lips either like i don't
think she looked bad yeah yeah then lips
but at the same time yeah she got lip
fillers and created a billion dollar
business with her makeup brand yeah i
feel like if if you could tell me same
thing as you if i got like plastic
surgery tomorrow and then i was able to
make a billion dollars off of some like
i don't know wellness brand
or like makeup brand i would absolutely
do it yeah and she doesn't seem like
yeah
i don't know my thumbnail i don't know
this i don't know this world
but it doesn't seem like she's
still doing a lot to her face at all
is that is that fair to say or am i
tripping i think that's because she has
the best plastic surgeons in the world
a lot of people now do very little
things where you very subtle little
things where you can't tell that they
have plastic surgery
unless you kind of know what procedures
you could do to make these little
details change no that's fair it's just
like improving your natural look now
would you would you just like dudes
dudes what would you want to do
so uh first and foremost i want to get
plugs
i'm starting to thin out on my head
i'm going to miss that as soon as it's
more noticeable i'm getting and planned
and there's i'm not going to say any
names yeah there's a lot of comedians we
know that have that is that who you're
going to say that's one of them right
yeah who else brian cowan that's that's
another one they failed
transplant
phil
yeah ask nick nick would you edit it out
oh yes yes you might remind me on uh
okay
oh they're so good then yeah they look
great a lot of people also get are
getting videos
i swear to god
and i wouldn't my teeth are okay i don't
hate myself
yeah
yeah i'd get the plugs
i'd get a nose job yeah
and i would laser my skin just to make
it look a little younger a little less
sun damage things oh you can't
microneedling for that that's really
common yeah maybe something like that
mm-hmm and i think that's it if there
was an easy one to make myself taller i
would definitely do that oh in china
they'll break your legs and then re-put
it on and you grow like yeah but that
sounds too gnarly yeah
i'm nine
i'm five ten
yeah you better chill
five nine's fine i'd love to be six foot
mm-hmm i would love to girls girls on
their profiles don't they say five nine
and above no it's higher it's usually
like six foot yeah i feel like that's
what the dating
sites usually do oh there's like a viral
tick tock or meme like girls have like a
line at six feet yeah like on their yeah
that's hilarious that's so funny like
like a disneyland ride
yeah
that's [ __ ] must be this tall to
enter
or like girls going on dates saying like
oh i went on a tinder date with this guy
who says he's six feet tall apparently
i'm six feet tall too
yeah and a lot of guys apparently lie
about their height i don't do that but i
would like to oh i have a homie that
like he has these special boots
that give him a little um
that's that is there any surgeries you'd
get no i don't give a [ __ ] i feel like
there's something nick would get but i
want to fix my teeth one day teeth okay
you get a bag of chocolate cardio you
can go there's like uh
veneers what's you know like uh
it's like medical tourism you can go
like overseas oh like in turkey or
thailand p davidson has the fake teeth
matt rife joe boy
oh yeah joe coyle christie is amazing he
said that there's these are amazing 60
grand for some guy in beverly hills yeah
he went to the best guy yeah
one day i'm gonna do that have you seen
will compton
will compton has great veneers he posted
a before photo of him before veneers and
then him after it looks insane i didn't
i've seen he's got really good teeth and
i didn't know
yeah i didn't know they were veneers
either but now
that he posted a photo of it i was like
that makes perfect sense
they're crushing it
no yeah see those are his veneers oh
they look really good but that was
totally fine
it's crazy how much he can change you
yeah
look at the comments
dude if i get a little work
the only issue with those fake teeth is
you can't go too white some people don't
know that like a
crystal crystally like clear bright
white color isn't natural yeah so
they're like i want the white like
toilet white these and then that
porcelain white and then you put it on
you look so they start to yellow over
time though maybe you get it that way
because they get all like some use yeah
maybe it looks weird for the first few
months or something i don't know it's
like ross and friends yeah just glowing
neon uh but these three teeth are a
bridge which means like this one came
out and then they take one piece and
they attach it to these two and so like
they had to like this is like colored
like a little
a little bit shaded so it matches like
my old teeth which means i can never
whiten my teeth because this wouldn't
change
don't you get braces bro
uh you can't with the bridge it's like
[ __ ] up i don't know bro yes you can
man my homie he's had his dentistry for
a minute
typing
watch i'm gonna show you some pictures
no they're not that bad
watch what hold on i thought we were
brothers go to instagram i think that's
why he's telling you because you're
probably dental work
a lot of people i know growing up in san
diego they would go to tijuana yeah
dental work because like half the price
so he has a touring acl we might take
seven uh it would be fun
dr dr oh never mind you don't have an
instagram logged in yeah i'll respond to
you
oh i was going to show you hold on maybe
i could share like this
a lot of girls get bbl's into you wanna
too
yeah i don't get that you don't get the
tijuanas or the bbs all the above like
if i was getting stuff done in my body
i'm paying top dollar for that yeah i'm
not gonna go to mexico and get some yeah
i feel like so many people want to like
ball on a budget on certain things and
go overseas but i can almost understand
it if you
if you speak the language of that
country but if you're like say me and i
go to tijuana to get like my boobs done
or something i don't know how to speak
spanish i don't know how to like
navigate that i would never risk i it's
also i'd rather do there's so many
botched
tit jobs that happen i need to be able
to sue that doctor if they watch my tip
job and you're not suing someone you got
to be like double day
what
that's spanish but yeah
i used to go to the brothel in tijuana
sometimes it's called the hong kong
mm-hmm
yeah there's one called i've been to
tijuana quite a few times i entered a
hot competition when i was like 19 and
[ __ ] did you win no i lost to some
[ __ ]
metal militia dude you what you did a
body competition hot bod competition
what is that you just [ __ ] show off
your [ __ ] like the spring break once
you did this yeah wait wait you did a
hot body
keep that in mind i was
do you have pictures of this no i don't
have pictures of it he's a [ __ ]
right music
i've seen him as a cheerleader and the
only reason why i lost to that metal
militia dude because my body was way
better than his he had a bunch of
friends there because they did it off
they did it all popularity
this guy's looking for it do you think i
would have a hot bod competition online
i'm just looking at this hot butter yeah
that's a [ __ ] ugly butt but uh
as i was saying the same mustache as
already right now
so is that the size of jamal
yeah that's what i imagined myself as
did you just describe chappelle and his
cheerleading yeah chappelle at 19 that's
me
[Laughter]
i want to be a 19 year old
but yeah so the hong kong if you go
there it's a brothel mexico and i would
recommend you all go there if you've
never been even if you don't want to
participate and get paid for sex yeah
just a fun time there's taco truck
outside yeah it's like a strip club
and there's about a hundred mexican
women in there of all shapes and sizes
and a lot of them have the the tit jobs
nast job and some of them look
so awful it's oh it's like really bad
it's so bad and i'm just like i don't
know why anyone would want to do that to
themselves have you have you fooled
around with anyone at this hong kong
gentleman's club uh not with the tit
jobs and and but you got the regular
women i got yeah
there you go what's that cost
it's about 80 to 100 dollars do you
wanna steal servers so you pay eighty
dollars to the girl and then you have to
buy a room for the half hour i think
that's fifteen or twenty dollars and
then you gotta tip or you should tip i'd
recommend tipping so
you don't like could you read the room
for i don't know seven minutes
oh no
you can use it but you could rent for
the half hour and use it for seven
minutes which is what i did but
giving time back to the room yeah
you get 30 minutes and then they give
you like a five minute warning some
someone will knock on the door you're
like
funny [ __ ] nice notorious for running
the light give it time let me give you
some time jamal i'm not but jamal is
yeah yeah
yeah
so
you you're interesting
i think most
men
if if not have
dabbled in prostitution or escorts
has at least looked into it and
researched it and thought about it and
wanted to try it most people wouldn't
admit to that
but i've already admitted yeah podcast
what my friend went on this one site
the [ __ ] it was like for older women
uh i forgot what it was called it was
like facebook like no not facebook it
was like a
a site to where like it's specifically
is it like a sugar baby was it like
maybe cougar.com or something like that
another one but basically like
because i'm like is that a form of no
actually because he didn't have to pay
for it yeah maybe not there's also how
many guys actually go get happy ending
massages
like that's so kind of that's the same
[ __ ] i've never done that um but yeah
how do you guys take a girl out to
dinner and pay pay 80
what's the difference you know i'm tired
of denying it i went through a phase i
went through a hong kong phase in mexico
where i and that's fine i tried it i
don't think that's [ __ ] funny it was
uh i don't think that's weird i got it
out of my system yeah yeah how many guys
have gone to the red light district in
amsterdam it's very normal yeah
a lot more normal than we actually think
the closest i ever came was when i was
in vegas with theo we went to aerosmith
then i'm like by myself he like
does whatever he does and i just play
blackjack for hours get drunk and as i'm
walking up to the room like
one of the hottest black girls i've ever
seen in person like like obviously
prostitutes jamal's sister but man i i
like thought about it but i kept my
strength at my sister
did not you didn't do it
vegas is scary because right good for
you vegas it's illegal
constitution's illegal in vegas it's
there's brothels there's legal brothels
that are i think they're on the
outskirts right outside like the bunny
ranch where lamar yeah yeah yeah in
vegas itself it's illegal
so that it can get i don't know i'm not
that scared of it but if you get cut
like i knew a guy who got caught with
cocaine in vegas and had to spend a few
nights in jail oh so i just and i don't
party they used to be crazy about wheat
too like you didn't want to get caught
with vegas and weed now it's legal and
they have mobile dispensaries and people
sell you wheat out of their van and it's
like technically legal but
it's [ __ ] wild
damn good times good times y'all crazy
you're you're single now or no what you
have a girlfriend or something yeah why
oh i was gonna say you should go to hong
kong why would i go to hong kong for a
good time apparently
for the experience
no that's why you got to do it
he was just trying to explain how there
shouldn't be a stigma around it and
you're all offended that you said that
was a real word i guess i know i was
offended because
it's me and i i don't roll like that
that's why i want something like this on
my style exactly that's why you should
do it to
step out of your shoes no
i'm getting all [ __ ]
are you sweating yeah go with your
girlfriend no i i just don't uh
necessarily
i don't know like it's just it's just
weird
i don't know i just can't get what get
down with that stuff my [ __ ]
because first of all i always think
someone's plotting on me
all right so my [ __ ] paranoia
is like
we already talked about this on fire in
a kid remember you get paranoid from
caffeine i get paranoid yeah exactly i
just get paranoid and [ __ ] i'm like
who's plotting on me who's trying to set
me up or whatever blah blah blah so i
just think
you could go and not participate you
could go to the hong kong you just want
me to look at it and not get a problem
yeah it's like a show club but it's a
mexican ship club where they get from
yeah i mean like legit legit strip clubs
where it's just like if me you
and your girlfriend were in san diego
doing a show or something
would would you go with me to san diego
would you with if and she was coming to
no no you wouldn't do it hard pass
okay listen i i don't know i'm such a
[ __ ] nerd and just like a kind of
like
i don't know i just don't want to like
yeah you're going to be off into what
you're saying
yeah i'm just don't listen to ari
everything is right that's what i'm
saying i'm not saying you're wrong i'm
not saying but like when it comes to
that world like that like i just don't i
don't know i just [ __ ] i get stressed
out i started sweating i started
questioning everything so it's like
why would i like i don't i don't like
having that kind of anxiety i like my
sanity
and i do really good at holding my
sanity pretty damn strong and i know if
i just did anything of that nature or
whatever i would be so [ __ ] stressed
out
so i just like keep to myself
you know what is the like the vibe like
do they yeah
into it or is it very transactional
because yeah all that [ __ ] like i think
i've had both experiences overall they
pretend to be into it but i think some
of the really
uh more beautiful
like the better the better they're hot
[ __ ] some of the girls like the hot one
time went and the hottest one there was
like
kind of an [ __ ] and you could tell
she just thought of herself as hot [ __ ]
and then another time i went where there
was just more girls and was more
competitive and they they're hustling
more
they're very nice they pretended me into
it i remember at one time the girl like
as we were hooking up was like
your girlfriend must be so jealous or or
no you like your girlfriend must love
yourself or something like that and i
didn't have a girlfriend yeah she's
gonna be no i didn't have a girlfriend i
never told her i had to go and she
thought that would turn me on
and she goes like no and she was like
because i knew it just felt so fake and
she said like you're so big i don't know
if i could handle it like i don't know
if i could take you like i'm like you're
a mexican prostitute
handled 10 guys tonight like what are
you talking about so i think i figured
it out yeah
substance
it lacks substance yeah for sure and so
like that's the thing with me like
i don't know it's just like that that
doesn't appeal to me because it lacks
substance but again i just want you to
go and check it out i don't want you to
you want me to look too yeah i just want
to look you want me to look at you [ __ ]
a process no no no i just want to go
there and get a drink with you at the
bar but i don't see it
get a non-alcoholic drink i just wanna i
just want to take you there so you can
see i think ari wants to rent out a room
with you i know right what are you
trying to do
i don't know if i'm in that wet t-shirt
contest i know
i knew you'd go
uh but i wouldn't get one either like
drinking the bar and people i've gone
before and not gotten a girl i went with
uh ali makovsky once and we went and we
just looked around
30-minute drive 30-minute drive yeah so
we went and i was like she's like i'd
love to see that and we went we got
tacos didn't get girls completely normal
because of see like with the prostate
you feel like you'd want to try things
that you haven't
done like any you can have sex with a
girl you've had something you're 69 with
this have you ever have you thought
about buying two at a time i've
definitely thought about it i haven't
done it but yeah that's i'm sure that
can be arranged or what about this
three at a time you could do that and
it's not that much money
and here's here's a rent suite and you
can get a bunch of girls up there yeah
so you got to upgrade the room i'm sure
you could pay more for like anal stuff
like that i i don't i haven't dabbled
yeah into it and i'm kind of past i have
a girlfriend now yeah yeah yeah i'm not
really oh yeah so
and also like i like
i don't think it's wild that other
people do that right i think it's wild
for me
you know what i mean like that's like
that like to me like i agree that's why
i wanted to see you know everybody has
their like bar yeah how wild they'll
[ __ ] go
and mine's [ __ ]
not that hard um when i was in amsterdam
with you
drunk all the time beat the [ __ ] out of
people you're fine you've
you've felt these rushes yes yes when i
was in amsterdam with theo
it was because for me growing up hearing
about amsterdam all you hear about is
mushrooms the red light district weed
coffee shops at this point i didn't care
about the weed or the mushrooms because
i had done it a bunch of times and it's
basically illegal in california now yeah
but i was like red light district i
gotta go check it out even though i was
kind of past my prostitute phase okay a
few one days this is when theo and i did
europe mm-hmm so i was like hey theo
want to go to real life he goes no i'm
good he's so he's like but you go so i
went and i'm like circling the red light
i called my brother i was like
do i want to i would sing a lot of time
but i was like do i want to get a
prostitute like he's like i think you
should do it because you're never going
to be there again you're like you're
never going to get another chance to do
that that's fair so i was like okay you
talked me into it didn't take much
talking into and then
i did
i did you're like thank you 19 year old
brother for the election yeah yeah yeah
so
i did two laps around the red light
district i really wanted to pick out my
woman you know i picked that one up you
did some window shopping yeah i did
window shopping i picked the hottest one
yeah i'm nervous i've never been there i
don't really know how it works so i
knock on the door i go in
and right away she's so mean she's like
what do you want i'm like uh sex i mean
i'm like how much is it she's like how
much is what i'm like to have sex and
she's like 100 euros i'm like okay
sounds good um i was like does it does
that include a [ __ ] like i'm just
asking questions she's like she's like
yeah and i'm like do i need to wear a
condom for the [ __ ] and she's like of
course you need a condom what are you
stupid like why would you ask me that
and i'm like i'm sorry i don't know i've
never done this before she's like so
mean to me i'm like okay here was she
gorgeous gorgeous
but i'm like
man this this lady's a [ __ ] yeah yeah
and so are they all dutch or they come
from everywhere they come from
everywhere i don't know i think i don't
know dutch is such a harsh language she
was she's probably being kind she was so
mean i like i get it you don't like your
job
but i'm like i'm a little bit cute i'm
being nice i don't know how it works
you're not coming in with crazy energy
no i'm not coming in craziness so
at this point i'm too chicken to back
out i should have just been like no
thank you i'm gonna go find someone else
but yeah but i'm like okay here's 100
euros
and we're hooking up and she's just
laying there
dead dead fish
i think she's her own i think they're
their own bosses in amsterdam so
she's just not into it and then like i
like went to um take out her tits right
i like go to take her down and she like
pushes my hand away she's like that's
extra mid [ __ ] right we're having sex
she pushes my hand away goes that's
extra i'm just like sorry okay that
one's on here and then
and then i like straight up go soft
because i'm just so turned off yeah
cause it's [ __ ] yeah
think about like
she's just laying there and just like
yeah not into it so i'm like yeah can't
keep my erection now she's berating you
so then
then she actually she finished off with
her hands like a pro she was good and
then um i left so she finished with a
handy shoe yeah but it was one of the
worst sexual experiences of my life oh
the head i mean wow that has the hands
down that's [ __ ] insane that is not
what i would have envisioned like a red
light district experience
and i'm not saying that's everyone's
experience i'm sure there's girls that
are very nice and pretending you know or
are into it but i thought you were gonna
say like you had like a dope experience
yeah
like a deuce bigelow situation yeah i
went home and i thought that mcdonald's
on the way and just had a night of shame
i think there's a very important
takeaway here it's a fool's errand to go
for the hottest prostitute
yeah they're too comfortable too
comfortable
who's going to work so yeah you so so
the goal is to not get a veteran
you gotta get someone that's like yeah
yeah yeah because you're there because
i'm thinking like i want a girl so hot
that i really wouldn't be able to get
her in real life
but yeah i guess but then they treat you
like that
yeah and then you go soft so yeah lesson
learned if you're out there maybe some
guys are into that some girls some guys
want a girl that's really mean to them
i'm not into that yeah what if that's
her specialty and she thought that's
what you were like going for
he's like god am i not doing good jobs
going soft yeah
damn ari i'm sorry that was your worst
i literally thought he was going to tell
like a story where he's like yeah but
then she was [ __ ]
fabulous
the ones the ones in tijuana were better
huh they had better attitudes better at
it yeah they had better attitudes
they had a can do spirit about yeah
yeah man this podcast got sexual huh
yeah yes uh it was very informative i
think it was it was more so you think i
feel like i present it in a way that
doesn't make me seem like a giant
scumbag but i could be wrong you have a
sexual energy about you but not in like
a raunchy way right i'm hoping
that if someone's listening to this
they go like he's just honest and
vulnerable and not thinking like ari's a
scumbag pervert yeah because i don't
view myself as that
no one who knows you really does they
like like
he's really nice is what i hear thank
you yeah i'm nice i like sex i like
comedy yeah you kind of you kind of like
it's weird like you're not
i'm not saying like one note but like
you kind of just like
hey this is what it is
it's what it is it's chill i i try to be
chill but yeah my fear like as i'm
saying all this stuff on this podcast
because i know probably thousands of
people are listening to this right part
of me is scared like i think we do we do
pretty damn what if my future wife is
listening to this right now and it's
like
[ __ ] i'm not dating that your future
wife wouldn't
i do have that thought creep up as we're
talking about this like do i want this
stuff on the internet but same time it's
like that's me that's honest that was my
past i did that i'm the same way with
[ __ ] i'm like that's i don't know like
sometimes i feel weird even though i
don't [ __ ] say much
you know
yeah i don't see anything but like even
sometimes i'm still like that was that
okay
you know i this is why i hate the
[ __ ] world making me question what
the [ __ ] i see on a goddamn podcast
you know yeah you can't even see the
n-word anymore yeah i never did really
begin with me neither you know
prior to my uh being adopted into the
white family you know living with my mom
and you know my stepfather growing up
and [ __ ] you know what that was never
said in the house
ever and i grew up in one of those
households i had friends like that never
sat in our house
um
i don't know but it was just kind of it
was kind of just understood
that it just wasn't a word like
you use right like none of my siblings
like
use that
at all yeah when i think about it none
of my siblings
that's probably a good thing yeah yeah
yeah
actually my sister did say one time and
my mom flipped out on her yeah yeah she
was like don't say that
and that not and she didn't say hard r
you know she just said
colloquially
did your uh mom give like a reason like
was she like
she just it was just ugly to her like it
was just like dude
she didn't think of it like as a classy
uh way to talk yeah you know what i mean
like that's how she thought of it
you know which is where it was just like
when i think about why i don't use it
yes
none of us none of us said it in our
home
there's the term for jews the k word no
one in my family used that what is that
that's like the n word for jews or i
don't think it's as i don't think y'all
loosely just say that as like no no
one's i've never heard really just
saying that but that's if you wanted to
say yeah it was weird like my mom didn't
care like
obviously with rap music and like like
obviously like that being played in the
house and stuff
you know but she just didn't like
her kids were not going to use that word
we're listening yeah no sorry i was
nice
those reflexes damn i want that i want
that reflex i already looked at you
catching that magic mine
dude natural born athlete he is flying
he used to catch women's ankles like
that when he cheerleader he is plotting
on me uh ari do you know what's in your
hands
i believe this is my favorite oh yeah
healthy shot you're sponsored by them
aren't you ma i have been in the past
magic mine yeah the once daily shot the
anti-procrastination drink with 12
natural ingredients that will uh give
you a nice send focus throughout the day
go to magic mind dot co slash dark promo
code dark for 20 off ashwagandha
ashwagandha what's up it's a place in
africa okay yeah the cool thing about
magic mine is when i take it i feel like
a black guy
okay you like jamal you feel like it
just makes me like my reflexes better my
energy better i'm more confident
so that's what i like about magic mine
well shout out jamal jamal [ __ ]
wait how how long we've been wait no
yeah it's it's definitely time to go uh
but
i do have a question for you too like uh
you guys are on the comedy scene both up
and comers like
i think i think uh chappelle made it
yeah shout out to chappelle he's
headlining touring headliner [ __ ]
killing the game doing everything i
dream of doing do you feel like you made
it
uh
not yet
good dude when i met chappelle
living in arizona yep
and was like hosting at the comedy clubs
right it was like a house mc
at the at the arizona common clubs nice
guy funny guy but like you know i meet
those all over the road so i didn't
think anything of it he moves to l.a
killed instantly just everyone loves
them killing it passed at all the comedy
clubs headlining gets on all the
podcasts so cool badass
that was just power
i was waiting for it i was like he's not
done though i was like
i'm really proud of you i was like
listen i'm really proud of you and i'm
jealous but in like the most supportive
best yes yeah you've always been very
supportive and yes i met ari and ari
look at him
who do we need legarre he's he's uh
go on he's here he's uh
there's so many great things to say
about this gentleman
is uh actually um
no one can deny he's here right now no
one can deny i just
this is real talk i feel like
someone's going to see you and be like
that's a [ __ ] guy right there
i'm telling you like
you have a very your delivery on
everything and the weight and the [ __ ]
that you talk about and the [ __ ] that
you're comfortable with talking about
and you know you have this edge to you
but like
they look at you and you're like just
kind of like this dude you when i first
saw him i was like oh this guy caught me
off guard i know i did not think that's
what he was gonna [ __ ] talk about but
but like i i feel like
you're gonna be someone that i'm like
the person one person just has to
[ __ ]
see him and acknowledge it and then boom
thank you very much you'll get there i
probably thank you yeah yeah no i'm not
i'm not worried and my life's very
that's good that's good because a lot of
people do worry even if my life stayed
as it is now like obviously i have goals
comedy goals i want a headline i want to
do all these things that you're doing
but even if that never happened and i
was deovon's feature yeah or whatever
whoever's feature
i'm happy you seem patient which is
which is a very important thing
especially out here there's days where
i'm impatient but overall when i really
sit back and look at take an outside
perspective of my life i'm like my
life's great i got i got a roof over my
head i eat whatever i want i travel all
the time i got a car that runs
i don't have roommates what else do i
don't need anything everything else is
just bonus see that that's how i think
of it too not to get too too [ __ ]
deep but like i don't know like
i feel like you're you're also a person
you understand like hey i do this thing
called comedy i do all these things but
also i like to be a person i feel like
you actually like to be
a person as well yeah you know
definitely and so do you your music yeah
yeah that's super important yeah like
for it to be a comic like you have to go
out and experience have life experiences
have stuff to talk about you will only
be at a comedy club every single night
of your life and and and i tell you what
like i've seen it many times with people
that are like you got to grind you got
to grind and people that do this grind
they always burn themselves out every
[ __ ] time because they're like you
have to be doing this
24 7. there's times i'll go a week
without touching the stage
and i don't feel like i [ __ ] missed
out on anything
and then there's probably comics that go
and do one spot and then just hang out
at the comedy club all night and they're
like oh i'm yeah i'm like i'm doing it
every night but yeah yeah there's some
people who just want to feel like
they're part of the community part of
the community yeah but my question was
who are people we need to look up for
up-and-comers like scene that we're
going to see and probably guys we can
have in here
okay you go first and i'll name some
after uh jb smooth
yeah that guy needs a that guy needs a
leg up
somebody needs to get that guy that's
that's a good question i would have to
oh darry spin it oh he's great
he's killing around town i feel like
yeah a lot of people are shouting him
out he's hilarious jerry spinning is
[ __ ]
i've stored a guy at the comedy store a
former door
is um i think he just auditioned for new
jfl new faces yeah i wouldn't be
surprised if he got that is matt
lockwood like definitely yeah definitely
exactly i was on i was done i had an
uncut's podcast with him i was like this
guy's [ __ ] hilarious now he follows
all the social media his podcast is
great dude he's doing good on tv he's
doing yeah he's doing really good matt i
just had him feature for me in uh
salt lake city that's the first time
i've taken him on the road and i've
always thought matt was funny and
it was just a [ __ ] delight to have
him like open up for me and
he just did so [ __ ] good with those
crowds and he i love that he owns
everything about himself and is very
honest about everything about himself
and it's like no gimmick or anything
like it's just like [ __ ]
straight up just [ __ ] matlock yeah
he's authentic he's yeah he's a good
hang off stage great guy really funny
mm-hmm uh bruce gray who's great
he's great [ __ ] tommy star really
super funny hi
steven garza just got passed to the
comedy yeah but still i feel like
stephen fury oh it's even furious
honestly it's it sucks because
i feel like i i mean i wasn't around in
the 80s the last comedy boom
but there's so many funny comedians
that
you don't think the mid 2000s was a
comedy boom or like in the late 2000s
early 10s like i felt like comedy so
everybody has special yeah i think
common sources yeah every night comedy
central presents oh you're talking like
right before covet or winning no he's
talking about maybe like maybe like five
years before yeah he's talking about
he's talking about like yeah yeah i
think i mean but sorry i didn't i
stepped on your point oh no no you're
good i was just saying there's so many
great comedians there's so many that
dessert like deserved could could
headline that are so funny they have
hours of material there's so many like i
i complain about my [ __ ] but there's so
many guys funnier or just as funny that
that aren't even where i'm at so it's
it's uh it's a competitive game there's
a lot of comedians you need there's so
many factors to having a career in
comedy it's like you need to
be on podcast now you need to know how
to edit video you need to have famous
guys that like you you need another bit
there's so much to it there's so there's
so much to it it's i mean also like i
mean i i feel like i'm having the time
of my life with it
you know
for sure you know especially ever since
i moved to l.a in general i feel like
i've just [ __ ]
been having more fun with comedy than i
think i've ever had before even before i
went full time with comedy it was still
like it's just so much [ __ ] fun like
i don't know it's crazy there's so
there's so many great
great comics out there that are [ __ ]
i mean there's certain ones that i'm
like man they're about they're they're
gonna pop
you just you can just feel it you see it
and then all of a sudden sometimes it'll
happen to where it's like where the [ __ ]
did that [ __ ] go
you know like where they just kind of
disappear but that's probably their own
[ __ ]
but
you know if they keep on the path you
know there's some there's some dope ones
is there anybody in mind that you're
like he disappeared and you're like i
thought this guy was going to be great i
feel like you were thinking about it
yeah there was someone and we're
probably thinking the same guy
i don't know where the [ __ ] he's at and
i i had him feature for me and
uh
what the [ __ ] was that north carolina
malcolm
oh malcolm hatchet malcolm hatchet yeah
i don't know what happened to him he was
like he wasn't killing it he remember
i remember we all thought he was going
to be in 2018 when i moved to l.a
and i saw him do a performance on kill
tony
and he [ __ ] just
annihilated this main stage at the at
the comedy store in front of this
[ __ ] crowd
he came across tony regular instantly
instantly i think he got signed with
like three arts three yards of caa like
dude it was so [ __ ] yeah he was like
auditioning for big [ __ ] every comedian
was like he's the next guy he's the next
uh what's his name uh
chris tucker no i was thinking who's the
guy who has who just put out the comedy
special where he's gay now gerard combo
yeah i was like he's oh yeah yeah
because and they also came from come
from the same city android camo gave him
money or a car or something i was like
that's the next guy and people were
people were rooting for this guy and i
don't know like and and it's not to
knock him like i still see like he'll
post like on on instagram but like
he was one that i was just like oh this
is about to [ __ ] be in everything i
thought he'd be headlining and have a
special right now yeah you know who was
really funny who quit comedy
uh ben avery tim dillon's uh producer
yeah oh he was stand up he did stand up
and he was really funny um
so
i was another one too quick i get it
it's like he has you know he's doing
good with him he doesn't need like he
was probably tired of doing open mics
for free and like hustling for nothing
it's a grind that you really have to
love doing because
most of the time
you're gonna do it for 10 years and lose
money
and i think ben was probably he you know
he got a wife he's he has this good job
now he feels i don't know i'm speaking
for him so i don't know yeah that's what
i'm saying
and i don't want to speak for malcolm in
his situation but it was just one person
that i've thought about uh thomas dale
oh yeah thomas dale would go out and
[ __ ]
kill kill in like the shittiest room in
it like everybody could everybody on the
lineup could have done bad but if you
saw thomas dale on that [ __ ] lineup
he was going to [ __ ] light that room
up and then
and now he's a psychic yeah he doesn't
like me he doesn't like my energy
oh yeah he zoomed in on cats i tried to
do like a medium reading and he could
just tell he was really skeptical that
he's like
he thought and his energy was intrusive
i think i uh which is fair yeah yeah i
think that's tired like i already said i
don't want to speak for these people in
their situations
but but like there's people that i think
about as far as like
you know
just
part of part of the game is sticking
with it
because yeah there's people who i'm like
if they stayed with it who knew like
ben if he stayed with it would probably
be at least featuring for tim i would
assume
but yeah i don't know yeah but it's it's
weird yeah but i get it i've there's
been days where i'm like should i quit
this i'm kind of burnt out so
well what do you want to plug ari
were you headlining are you uh
headlining nowhere no i'm headlining uh
mike drop the new club in san diego yeah
nice coming up
i did it it's great yeah it's great yeah
i did it once as well uh my podcast
unlicensed therapy
there's an episode with nick on there
there's an episode with chappelle
there'll be an episode of cat if she's
wanting to do it yeah whatever so yeah
check that podcast out well thanks for
having me yeah cool thanks for coming
back yeah we learned a lot about jewish
culture today jewish culture
prostitution if i was a black guy over a
lot of things so [ __ ] comedy hong
kong
booming uh spot and teal when you go to
hong kong with your boyfriend
i would now i'm curious i don't know i
took my boy my boyfriend and i go
everywhere together so i want to say yes
but i feel like he wouldn't want to go
that's something that like i feel like
if we were hanging out and you said hey
you want to go to hong kong i'd say [ __ ]
yeah and then he'd get upset with me
when i got home he's like what the [ __ ]
are you doing what if he came though if
he came i think he'd absolutely calm but
like to supervise to make sure i'm not
doing something stupid
because i don't know any better and i'll
get lost he's invited you're all invited
let's have a hong kong party that'd be a
fun vlog
and then chappelle's just running off
somewhere i don't want to go in
i just run back to my hotel and journal
i'm like i can't take this [ __ ] today i
was approached by the devil his name was
jamal
uh
check it out
uh check out another podcast show uh
still trying to get it hold of mitch
mcconnell so far he's not uh responding
my buddy wants to box him
um well actually mma uh and uh yeah
we're doing some fun stuff on there i
ate dog ate a dog treat
the other day just to bump up the
numbies so we're doing some fun things
over there another podcast show
george uh i have a new channel called go
george go i'm the newest intern here i
am vlogging and learning my way through
this fun podcast world so check it out
please and thank you oh yeah
uh always check out my podcast
chappelle's world and then uh june
what is that show i think it's june 2nd
is the show that i'm doing in london at
the 100 club
uh then
also in june june 24th to 25th i'll be
in providence rhode island headlining
the comedy connection and i think
meatball's gonna be there hanging out
with me but uh tickets at
chapelleacy.com
yeah you can check me on
onlyfans.comteen
and my instagram same handle all right
and check out the link tree link not the
only fans link oh i can't you can't
channel taken down oh yeah you can't you
can't do those you gotta you gotta put
the link tree only you get shadow band
like that i've been shadow band for
honestly at least a year hard warning
like a soft shadow band not like the
hard like
i think it just got taken off thank god
thanks instagram all right london i'll
see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
you